severe staffing shortages from fox news
severe static shortages at the san
francisco police department paired with
the local prosecutor's criminal first
agenda is creating
a dangerous situation on city streets
headed into the summer months according
to union president
tony montoya after one of his officers
left patrolling alone in chinatown was
violently tackled to the ground by a
homeless man until bystanders intervened
now this is we have the security camera
footage it was released by the union
and uh you can see there's a homeless
man he was causing i don't know what he
was doing i think he was
he was harassing people random people
the cops are called
one cop shows up to the scenes a female
police officer
she tries to arrest him he tackles her
to the ground
and she's now powerless at this point
because
this is a this is a big guy he's a large
man
and uh who knows if he's on drugs or
whatever and he's on top of her
and it takes a whole bunch of
bystanders intervening to pry him off
and maybe save her life
let's take a look at the at the video
here we have the security camera footage
and she is completely outmatched
she's a you know a woman small of
stature
this guy's on top of her
one bystander intervenes that's not
enough another guy comes up
another guy who runs out and they need
four guys
and eventually other police officers
show up all right
so i mean that that's uh you
talk about curt so there's some real
courage i think to to
be a bystander and so often in these
situations we've seen this a million
times
um usually something like that the the
footage we would see
that was the security camera footage but
usually we're not getting security
camera footage we're getting cell phone
footage because the bystanders rather
than intervening
and doing the right thing they just sit
around filming it so that they can be
the first one to get it on social media
and get all those sweet social media
likes
and hits uh but in this case bystanders
did the right thing got involved um
which
which they should be lauded for that
but there's so much going on here to be
analyzed
first of all when you
defund police departments
and you have fewer police this is the
kind of thing that happens
now if those bystanders had not run in
to help her what would have happened
she could have been killed or she would
have been
fully justified and that doesn't mean
that she wouldn't end up getting
prosecuted for it by the way but she
would have been fully justified
especially if she didn't have any help
she would have been fully justified in
pulling out her gun and just shooting
the guy
because now she's in a fight for her
life she's in mortal danger she's got
this large
intoxicated crazy guy on top of her
and uh she's in fear for her life so she
would have been fully justified in
pulling out her gun and shooting him
it didn't go that way largely because
other people intervene if they weren't
there
then that could have gone a fatal
direction
because she's just one police officer
there dealing with this
and that's the thing when you have fewer
police officers there's actually
no you don't end up with less violence
you end up with more violence in the
community because there are fewer people
there to enforce the law
but even the the interactions with the
public
and police become more dangerous for
everyone involved
because they don't have backup they
don't have help they're they're going to
have to more quickly resort to
um to lethal means to defend themselves
in situations like this
and then also you know we have to
mention we've got the issue of um
the fact this is a female police officer
by herself patrolling responding to a
call like this
and credit to her i mean that that takes
courage as well but
what's what's the plan here
this is not this woman there are very
few
suspects especially men that this woman
would be able to
contain and take down on her own
even if you're a man even if you're a
large strong man
it still is very difficult to take
someone down
and contain them when they really don't
want to be
contained and especially if they're on
drugs
but for a woman it's there's almost no
chance
the police officers are not are not
ninjas this is not kill bill
they might be trained but there's almost
no chance that
that female police officer could have
been able to take that guy down
so what's the plan exactly you send
female cops out
by themselves
they can be easily overpowered by almost
any suspect
just disaster waiting to happen and that
could have been a disaster if not for
the uh
courage of the of the bystanders well i
hope you enjoyed that clip from the matt
wall show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content